[موسيقى]
ارى شخصيا وهذا بحثناه في الجزء السابع من
خطى العرب عن تاريخ المدافن ان الذي بنى
المدفن عند فهم الطريق كان الطريق موجوده
المدفن ولا لماذا اختار هذا الموقع عند
المدفن مع ان عنده خشوم كثيره
ورعان كثيره لجبل طويق وهذا المدفن الان
ثبت ليس فحصي ثبت ان هذه المدافن لا يقل
عمرها عن خمسه الاف عام من الوقت الحاضر
برونز او عصر حجري
[موسيقى]
تاريخ الجزيره العربيه لم يعطى حقه وربما
لم يدرس بعد
سواء درب ادي راب من الشرق من الجنوب عن
دربب الجد يعني بدون عده الطرق المحفوره
الاثريه والتي تصعد وتنزل على حجر اليمامه
قديما
درب اديراب
وهذا عمل والان طبعا السيارات حفرته وازيل
الدرب التاريخي للاسف
درب ابا القد يعني من الجنوب الى الشمال
اديراب ابلقت
مصيعط
زبيده زبيده غير السيده زبيده درب الحج
الكوفي السقطه المنجور كلها بقيت الا درب
اديره بوزيل لكن بقيت الدروب لكن اهمها
واوضحها الى اليوم دربه بالقد
[موسيقى]